[Musica]
allora uno degli aneddoti più divertenti
che ricordo risalgono la mia tesi di
laurea quando alcuni amici di parenti
chiesero a mia mamma
ma perché chiara studia briozoi io credo
che le immagini siano più eloquenti di
tante parole quindi lasciate che vi
porti e sott'acqua con me qui siamo
pochi centimetri sotto il livello del
mare
io sono sicura che voi avete trovato sud
i vostri piedi alcune di queste foreste
di animali le cosiddette animal forest
che sono costituite proprio da briozoi
vedete la ricchezza l'abbondanza di
organismi queste foreste ospitano a
parte briozoi che ne costituiscono la
struttura vermi che vedete con il loro
arco branchiale aperto pronti a prendere
cibo tanti altri organismi pesci piccoli
gamberetti stelle di mare
ora siamo appena usciti diciamo per così
dire da un periodo estremamente
difficile estremamente duro che è stato
quello dello clown
abbiamo ripreso un pochino delle nostre
attività ma io sono sicura che voi
ricordate molto bene la prima sensazione
che avete provato una volta usciti dal
vostro appartamento e avete fatto una
passeggiata in un bosco questo senso di
benessere è un senso che deriva dalla
natura ed è un qualche cosa non di
astratto ma che assolutamente è
misurabile le foreste che noi troviamo
in aria che è l'ambiente ovviamente in
cui noi siamo abituati da esseri umani a
vivere
esistono anche sott'acqua e sono
caratterizzate appunto da animali per la
maggior parte quindi questo senso di
benessere in realtà come vi dicevo è
assolutamente misurabile e gli
scienziati lo hanno fatto hanno
dimostrato per esempio che stare nella
natura e passare del tempo addirittura
per più di 30 minuti alla settimana
permette un miglioramento di tutta una
serie di funzioni fisiologiche per
esempio migliora l'umore migliora la
pressione sanguigna riduce il rischio di
malattie cardiovascolari ma chi è stato
il primo a dire che esiste una
connessione
profonda tra noi e la natura è stato
questo signore qua alexander von
humboldt un tedesco che è vissuto tra la
fine del settecento ei primi
dell'ottocento ed è stato definito da
darwin come uno dei primi grandi
esploratori uno dei primi grandi
naturalisti con un gold è stato molto
fortunato è nato da una famiglia molto
ricca che gli ha permesso di esplorare
il mondo ma per primo ha avuto
l'intuizione di capire come tutte le
componenti e dei sistemi viventi fossero
estremamente connesse
quindi le piante tra di loro gli animali
e naturalmente anche l'uomo quindi
davano in volta avviene diciamo la prima
indicazione di come di fatto esista una
connessione estremamente profonda tra
l'uomo e la natura
ora diamo un'occhiata al nostro pianeta
è un pianeta blu quindi i due terzi
della terra sono ricoperti da acqua
il sistema climatico dipende dalla
presenza degli oceani addirittura
influenza il 95 per cento del clima
ovviamente determinato da altro come
l'orbita terrestre
l'influenza di altri pianeti l'influenza
del sole bene in un pianeta blu
naturalmente anche il blu ha influenza
sulla vita dell'uomo il nostro corpo
come voi sapete per più del 70 per cento
costituito da acqua quindi in qualche
modo sì su una connessione profonda non
soltanto con l'ambiente terrestre ma
anche con il nostro oceano
ma quali sono le dimensioni che regolano
l'oceano e bene abbiamo il clima abbiamo
visto che l'oceano ha una funzione
estremamente importante a livello di
regolazione del clima ma non solo
l'uomo ha un influenza a livello del
sistema oceanico e gli ecosistemi marini
queste tre componenti sono in
connessione tra di loro vuol dire che si
influenzano reciprocamente
quindi gli ecosistemi marini hanno un
ruolo estremamente importante ma che
cosa sappiamo oggi noi della
biodiversità per darvi un'idea si stima
l'esistenza di più di 10 milioni di
specie di questi 10 milioni soltanto 2
milioni ne conosciamo immaginate la
vastità di quello
non conosciamo non conosciamo a livello
terrestre dove noi possiamo arrivare ad
diciamo conoscere approcciare tantissimi
ambienti pensate all'ambiente marino che
ha così ostico difficile è un ambiente
in cui noi non siamo abituati
naturalmente a stare è bene gli
ecosistemi marini sono estremamente
importanti
allora ritorniamo alla domanda perché
ibrido zoi i briozoi come tanti altri
ecosistemi marini hanno un ruolo molto
importante che abbiamo visto nello
schema precedente perché sono in grado
di fornire dei servizi o meglio è stato
quantificato un contributo della matura
all'uomo come lo percepiamo bene abbiamo
detto per esempio se ci rapportiamo agli
ecosistemi terrestri un benessere legato
ad un azione fisiologica su quelle che
sono le caratteristiche fisiologiche
dell'uomo quindi ci permettono per
esempio se pensiamo alle foreste queste
producono ossigeno attraverso
fotosintesi quindi ci aiutano respirare
ed hanno un'azione così detta di
regolazione cioè regolano il clima ma
questo non lo fanno soltanto gli
ecosistemi terrestri lo fanno
naturalmente anche agli ecosistemi
marini pensiamo per esempio alle foreste
sommerse costituite da piante le
cosiddette fanerogame marine la
posidonia oceanica che è una pianta che
presente il mar mediterraneo
ma non solo noi il benessere che
proviamo andare a passeggio in una
foresta a vederla e verde i colori fiori
bene queste hanno un valore di tipo
culturale ci dicono che la bellezza è un
valore che può essere monetizzato e
questa monetizzazione ha ovviamente un
importanza anche sulla vita dell'uomo e
ovviamente i sistemi di supporto come
sistemi di supporto la biodiversità
pensate all'immagine che abbiamo visto
all'inizio quindi questo riff
meraviglioso questa foresta di animali e
tutti gli animali che ci vivono
all'interno i pesci quelli che
utilizzano la foresta per la protezione
dei loro piccoli e via discorrendo
quindi esiste di fatto un qualche cosa
che diciamo da un'idea di un servizio
che i vari ecosistemi e sia terrestri
che marini danno all'uomo
questi sono briozoi qui ci troviamo nel
mare di tasmania ad una profondità di 7
mesi
sembra un riff a coralli ma non è un
rifà corale ori fabrio gioia delle
estensioni che superano anche i
chilometri di dimensione qui ci troviamo
il mar mediterraneo questa è un riff che
si trova sotto casa mia è una specie che
io ho studiato durante la tesi di
dottorato si chiama piantato rafa cialis
e vedete l'abbondanza di pesci che
vivono attorno a questo rif
qui ci troviamo in antartide nel mare di
ross e questa foto mi è stata data da
anni ma che è un istituto che si occupa
di scienze in antartide della nuova
zelanda e questi sono briozoi ci
troviamo a circa 300 metri di profondità
quindi briozoi sono presenti sono
presenti dappertutto sono presenti ai
tropici ai poli a tutte le profondità
dalla superficie fino alle profondità
anche oltre 1000 metri ma che facciano e
brioso e vediamo di da vicino sono degli
animali coloniali quindi sono costituiti
da tanti piccoli individui che insieme
contribuiscono a formare una colonia
immaginatela come un palazzo
questo è il singolo individuo dove
abbiamo da qui esce un piccolo polipo
che la parte organica dell'animale che
esce per nutrirsi e tutta questa sua
struttura è uno scheletro hanno infatti
uno scheletro base di carbonato di
calcio o immaginate il guscio di nuovo
ma un pochino più dura e resistente sono
simili paragonabile ai coralli ma sono
evolutivamente un pochino più avanti che
cosa vuol dire vuol dire che bearzot e
sono stati in grado di differenziare le
loro funzioni all'interno della colonia
quindi abbiamo un esempio
questo è un individuo che si occupa
della riproduzione quindi la larva viene
prodotta all'interno di questa camera
che ha chiamato vi cella questi invece
sono i guardiani e difensori della
colonia levi cool arie hanno una specie
di mandibola che sa che si flette e che
in grado di catturare il predatore che
cerca di entrare nel buco per mangiare
la parte organica questa specie viene
dal mare di ross è stata una è oggetto
di uno dei miei progetti di ricerca gli
scienziati sono simpatici e non chiamate
rete porella frigida proprio che viene
da un ambiente estremamente freddo
ma perché a vela porto come esempio
perché il nome della specie che è
composto il nome del genere più la
specie il genere è un genere ubiquitario
e distribuito dappertutto questa station
a uno scheletro a base appunto di
carbonato di calcio di calcite pura
i brianzoli sono un po particolari per
questo che forse sono un po rognosi
nello studio perché sono in grado di
differenziare loro scheletro in due
forme a base di calcite di aragonite
qual è la differenza è molto semplice
sono comunque carbonato di calcio ma
alcuni atomi di calcio sono seguiti dal
magnesio nella calcite mentre nella
ragoni tejeda stronzio e voi mi direte
vabbè allora allora semplicemente questo
da delle caratteristiche differenti cioè
organismi che vivono in ambiente freddi
come la nostra rete porella anno e
soggetti anche a bassi ph perché
pensiamo al ph del mediterraneo dqha
intorno 8 e 1 circa in antartide può
scendere sotto gli 8 e 90 quindi
alterazioni di ph alterazione di
temperatura fanno sì che vengano
preferite delle specie con uno scheletro
base di calcite ora lo vedremo anche tra
poco ma questa specie presente
dappertutto questo genere presente
dappertutto anche per esempio nelle zone
ad emissione vulcanica di panarea dove è
l'unica tra le specie di briozoi che ora
diciamo con un progetto che amiamo
collaborazione con alcuni istituti
italiani sembra essere effettivamente
resistente delle condizioni molto
particolare di emissioni di co2 e di
altri gas presenti nelle zone profonde
di panarea
questo è un altro esempio è sempre un
brioso si chiama patti nella radiata ma
siamo e mar mediterraneo in particolare
a ischia questo sì questa signora qua è
in grado di crescere lungo un gradiente
di co2 nella zona punto emissioni
naturali di ischia
anche questa base di calcite quindi
questa specie è in grado di resistere
anche a condizioni di basso ph ma cosa
fa semplicemente riduce le sue
dimensioni rispetto alle condizioni di
controllo dove la colonia e più grande
in questo caso la colonia ha ridotte
dimensioni
quindi perché mi piacciono i briozoi
perché briozoi sono resilienti sono
presenti sulla terra da 450 milioni di
anni e sono ancora qua
cosa hanno fatto sono state in grado di
adattare
le loro caratteristiche dello scheletro
alle condizioni del mare che cambia
eccola qua questa è una specie che ho
scoperto io mi ero dimenticata ed è una
specie invece estremamente simpatica che
vi voglio presentare si chiama pianta
ora quindi appartiene al genere che
abbiamo visto prima e l'ho trovata
quando ho collaborato con il museo di
storia naturale quando siamo stati a
fare un esplorazione nel coro line fag
che è un affioramento nel suffolk in
inghilterra perché a questo aspetto
buffo perché originariamente questa
pianta porrà lacrima aveva uno scheletro
che era coperto di aragonite nel tempo
l'arago nito si è trasformata in calcite
e ha fatto sì che la nostra colonia
assumesse questo aspetto così strano un
po peloso penta por a un genere che
ancora oggi presente è presente in
mediterraneo ma anche presenti in
atlantico con diverse specie quindi
anche questo è un esempio di resilienza
di trasformazione oggi questa specie non
c'è più ma le specie che sono ancora
presenti le somigliano molto come vi
dicevo la resilienza nel bronzo e
risiede proprio nella loro capacità di
aver trasformato il loro scheletro
abbiamo detto che compaiono durante
circa lordo visciano quindi 400 oltre
450 milioni di anni fa e sono state in
grado di trasformare loro scheletro da
aragon etico a calci tico con
l'andamento della concentrazione di
aragonite calcite nei mari che ha un
qualche cosa che avvenuto ovviamente con
le trasformazioni nel pianeta oggi come
sono caratterizzati e vi dicevo che
hanno una mineralogia piuttosto
complessa quindi alte latitudini per
esempio l'antartide i poli sono
prevalentemente specie calciti che con
una piccola componente b significa b
minerali che possono avere un pochino di
aragonite nel loro scheletro
se ci spostiamo invece a basse
latitudini vedete che all'interno del
gruppo dei briozoi ci sono circa la
distribuzione tra tutte quante le
componenti dove mi hanno portato i
briozoi libero già mi hanno portato al
polo mi hanno permesso di fare
inversione sott'acqua e soprattutto di
creare un esperimento molto importante
che ci consente
tira di validare la loro importanza come
indicatori di condizioni ambientali in
cui vivono questo progetto che è stato
finanziato dal programma nazionale per
la ricerca in antartide ci ha permesso
di creare un laboratorio sottomarino
sotto il ghiaccio che abbiamo lasciato
per 12 mesi abbiamo raccolto specie
libero gioele abbiamo trapiantate in
queste gabbie che vedete qua a una
profondità di 25 metri e abbiamo
registrato per un anno i parametri
attraverso questa sonda quindi
temperatura ph salinità che cosa faremo
la nostra idea è quella di utilizzare lo
scheletro di questi organismi e di
ricostruire le condizioni ambientali che
loro hanno vissuto attraverso i loro
scheletro questo ci permette di validare
una cosa molto importante che nei
peggiori e sconosciuta cioè qual è
l'aspetto vitale qual è l'effetto della
parte organica di questi organismi nel
determinare la registrazione di queste
informazioni
se pensiamo di nuovo alla nostra penta
porrà la crema pensate che a 5.8 milioni
di anni allora magari studiando su
scheletro noi saremo in grado di capire
quali erano le condizioni ambientali in
cui questa specie è vissuta queste sono
alcune immagini della mia esperienza
sotto il ghiaccio che è stata veramente
incredibile quindi perché briozoi perché
briozoi mi hanno portato a girare il
mondo perché sono importanti sono
importanti perché l'abbiamo visto sono
in grado di formare riff e hanno un
valore estremamente rilevante per le
persone pensiamo di come i riff di
utilizzarli per poter riqualificare
degli ambienti estremamente impoveriti
la prima immagine che abbiamo visto è
stata scattata sotto un pontile quindi
un ambiente assolutamente impattato da
un punto di vista ambientale però loro
ce la fanno loro crescono
pensiamo ad un mondo dove riusciamo a
ridare a questi gli organismi il loro
spazio come riusciamo a ridarlo le
foreste di fanerogame come riusciamo a
ridarlo ai riff a coralli e bene questi
sistemi che siano basati sul sugli
ecosistemi permettono un adattamento un
adattamento all'uomo e un effetto di
mitigazione sullo stesso clima che porta
un miglioramento sugli ecosistemi
quindi che cosa vi voglio dire vi voglio
dire
come l'avete visto che la natura è parte
di noi
noi abbiamo assolutamente bisogno di
costruire la nostra resilienza
sentendoci parte della natura stessa ed
utilizzando la natura per le soluzioni
per il futuro
grazie
[Applauso]